were stories are like fire used wisely
they can power steam engine used
unwisely they burn down the whole
village there's a secret fighting forest
let loose and war zones that's above
international law and fighting in your
name global superpowers like the US
Russia and others are paying companies
to fight for them so what can go wrong
when armed civilians are doing the work
of the military hey guys I'm Shireen and
this Sunday on aj+ we're looking into
the multi-billion dollar industry of
private military contracting and how
modern warfare gets a lot more
complicated when you pay someone else to
fight for you
[Music]
remember at bond-athon
the US has been partially outsourcing
the war there for 16 years and Counting
the secretive fighting forces go by a
lot of names present military
contractors paramilitary groups and more
bluntly mercenaries but they're all
pretty much the same armed civilians and
battle zones engaging in military
conflict and making lots of money the
mercenary option is being used by
Vladimir Putin with fighters in Ukraine
and Syria by Nigerian leaders to combat
Boko Haram and even in the u.s. when the
private firm Tiger Swan was hired to spy
on pipeline protesters at the Standing
Rock reservation and this type of
fighting force is not new to find out
more we talked to Sean McFate a former
mercenary he clued us into the history
as stretching all the way back to the
Middle Ages for centuries they were
underground they were in the shadows and
places like the Congo and Africa and so
forth but the US military of all people
of all organizations has resurrected
mercenaries in the wars of Iraq and
Afghanistan after serving as a US Army
officer Sean worked for a private
security firm in Liberia and Burundi
there are more mercenaries around they
have more connections more experience
they're veterans and they are much more
powerful than they were even 20 years
ago so the u.s. is no stranger to the
concept of mercenaries the country has
contracted armed forces as far back as
World War two
during the recent wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan it's estimated that the
proportion of contractors to troops left
as much as 50 percent most of them were
hired to cook meals or translate for the
military but some of them did engage in
combat no one knows with certainty
exactly how many of these mercenaries
are on the ground today because the US
government doesn't keep track and that
obscurity is intentional they're
essentially an invisible fighting force
it's one of the reasons the US military
likes to use contractors according to
McFate they don't count as casualties
Americans get really upset if we
increase boots on the ground in a place
I have gas stand and they get even more
upset when our soldiers come back in
body bags but nobody asks
about private military contractor deaths
bill they tracks it nobody even knows
another reason the US military likes to
hire mercenaries is that it allows the
military to have a zero footprint that
means you can't trace responsibility for
risky mission or civilian deaths back to
the US government
they provide plausible deniability what
that means is when a mercenary does
something bad the US government can just
wash their hands and say oh those are
bad mercenaries that was a bad company
hold on we're about to explain what that
means for us right now the Trump
administration has been looking at using
more private military contracts in
Afghanistan and requested proposals from
two people who donated big to his
campaign Erik Prince ex-navy seal and
founder of the security firm Blackwater
donated a quarter of a million dollars
to Trump's campaign and the party and in
the previous two wars Blackwater
mushroomed to a billion dollar
contracting giant his new company would
likely profit from the latest push in
Afghanistan and money talks
Eric Prince's sister Betsy DeVos donated
about 2.7 million to Trump's campaign
and now holds a cabinet-level position
as education secretary if it was up to
Eric Prince his company would take over
the entire military operation and
Afghanistan and let's not forget about
Trump's other influential donor Stephen
Feinberg the owner of DynCorp he and his
wife paid about 2.2 million to the group
supporting Trump and his company DynCorp
already made 2.5 billion from the State
Department training a police force in
Pakistan even Trump's chief of staff
John Kelly was a DynCorp advisor before
joining the administration so why is it
so problematic these companies have a
direct line to the White House there is
almost zero accountability for
corporations in this business the world
of private security contracting isn't
regulated like a government agency and
that's dangerous for a few reasons
first visibility agencies like the
Department of Defense have mandatory
reporting obligations by nature of being
in the public sector and DOD decisions
can be openly scrutinized and second
Congress people have to answer to their
constituents and are under constant
pressure to end the unpopular wars
abroad private firms are free of these
pressures and they want to keep fighting
mercenaries breed conflicts mercenaries
are incentive
to start wars or elongate them they
don't have to obey your authority and
they can even work against you they can
be under bought by your enemy another
reason the increased use of mercenaries
might cause problems when you hire
private security firms everything they
do is proprietary and there are a few
consequences when things go wrong
remember these disturbing images from
Abu Ghraib in Iraq the u.s. run military
prison became infamous after private
military contractors and others carried
out abuses prisoners were stripped naked
and electrocuted 256 Iraqis sued the
firms CACI International and Titan
corporation for war crimes and cruel
inhumane and degrading treatment but the
Supreme Court shut down the case in 2011
another case against CI CI International
is still ongoing
then there's the Nisour square massacre
in Iraq in 2007 Blackwater contractors
open fire on civilians killing 17 people
and wounding 20 the incident sparked at
least five investigations but Blackwater
was never sentenced and the US
government is still working with its
current incarnation Michael Ratner a
human rights attorney who worked on many
of these cases at the Center for
Constitutional Rights told MSNBC there's
a culture essentially of impunity of
allowing excessive use of force allowing
reckless use of force that encourages
Blackwater employees to kill innocent
people even if the u.s. reversed its
strategy and eliminated military
contractors in Afghanistan it wouldn't
change the reach of the global industry
this is a multi-billion dollar industry
that is growing and it's not going to go
away I think whether America wants to do
it or not we're gonna be relying on
armed contractors going forward and it
will be a part of the American Way of
war in the reach of these groups doesn't
end with nations waging war it extends
to extractive industries like oil and
mining company is hiring armed security
and even mercenaries at sea guarding
shipping routes from Pirates private
mercenaries have the potential to up end
the status quo of global affairs so what
will our world look like when military
force becomes a commodity on the global
marketplace we just scratch the surface
when it comes to mercenaries and there
is so much more to consider what happens
when these invisible soldiers come home
and don't have any VA benefits
and what about the countries they're
invading and their sovereignty let us
know what you think in the comments and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe